ساذهب الان الى كيف معيافين ماكتينكو
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه سيد
مكتينكو اهلا بك معنا ما هو تعليقكم
الاولي على هذه المسيره التي تم استهدافها
بمحيط القصر الرئاسي
مساء الخير تحيات من كيف
كيف الان يعني تقريبا
يعني ليله قطعت الليله ولكن قبل الساعه ان
في الناس كثيرين اللي شافوا عده مسيرات
كانت فوق كيف ولكن انا لست متاكد بان فوق
الاداره الرئاسيه لان انا شفته بعيني وانا
ساكن يعني الى حد ما بعيد عن الاداره بس
كانت يعني مسيرات تدور يعني فوقنا
وقوات
مضاد يعني قوات الدفاع الجوي كانوا
[موسيقى]
من قاذفات ومن رشاشات
فالحمد لله
قدروا ان اسقطوا على اقل واحد
مسيره
وانا شاهد عينيه هل هناك من اي اضرار هل
هناك من اي اضرار او اي خسائر بشريه او
اصابات انا الان فتحت
الانترنت بعد من
مواقع اوكرانيه هو تؤكد بان عدسه حدسه هاي
تم هاي حدث قبل 40 دقيقه تقريبا والحمد
لله ما في شيء ولا ضرر ولا شيء ولا ولا
جرحى ولا قتله ولا حاجه
هل من الممكن نعم اكرر من جديد نحن للاسفه
الشديد
متعودين على
هاي مسيرات وهاي مسيرات للعصفور الشديد
هاي حياتنا منذ 14 شهر
وندبر حالنا
ولا هلا ولا ولا
حاجه يعني
هل التحقيقات لمعرفه اذا لانه هناك عده
روايات بانه من الممكن ان تكون هذه
المسيرات فيها متفجرات لاستهداف القصر
الرئاسي او محيطه او تكون اسم سيارات من
اجل التجسس هل هناك وقت طويل من اجل معرفه
طبيعه هذه المسيرات
انا برايي
الفكره الثانيه من اجل التجسس لماذا لما
تيجي هاي المسيره هناك عده مسيرات
واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه فهم يصورون يعني
الهم اهمهم يصورون
بيعرفوا مواقع
للاجهزه او مدافع للمضاده
المضاده للطيرات ومضاده للصواريخ هاي شيء
مهم في كل الحرب نحن في نعمل نفسه شيء
ولكن مش في روسيا في مناطق المحتله
الاوكرانيه اللي الان روسيا لا تزال تحتل
18 تقريبا في الميه من مناطق من مناطق
تابعه لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لسادتناكو عاده هل تعلمون من اين تنطلق
هذه المسيرات ام من الصعب معرفه ذلك
[موسيقى]
ولكن خيره الروس يتغيرون في بعض الاحيان
كانوا كنا منتظرين دائما من الجنوب الان
تيجي المسيرات من الشمال اما من بيلاروسي
ولكن هاي مش اكيد ولكن اكيد من منطقه او
محافظه اسمها برانسك في شمال في شمال
اوكرانيا ومحافظات اخرى ولكن لا تزال
مسيرات تيجي من من جنوب من جنوب اوكرانيا
من من يعني جنوب تقريبا روسيا طب سيد
مارتنكو هل تغيرت
طبيعه الاجراءات المامنيه المكثفه حول
المقر الرئاسيه ايضا مركز رئاسه الحكومه
الاركان بعد هذا الاستهداف بالامس وهذا
التصعيد والتهديد من قبل روسيا لاستهداف
واستهداف زيلينس كشخصيا واعضاء حكومته
انا اكرر لكم
وللمشاهدينا الكرام بان الان سيد الرئيس
الاوكراني في زياره رسميه في اوروبا
امبارح هو كان في فنلندا اليوم هو يزور
هولندا ويزور مدينه لاهاي وكمان القى كلمه
مفيده جدا ومهمه جدا
لكلمه
لا يوجد سلام بدون عداله هاي كان يتحدث عن
هذه الكلمه عن هذه الاشياء في
في مقر لمحكمه جنائيه دوليه في لاهاي فهاي
والله خطوه مفيده ومهمه جدا جدا جدا وهو
التقى كمان اليوم
بقاله هولندا اما
الخطه يعني القادمه انا ما اقدرش اقول لكم
حاجه
سيد مكتينكو ايضا هذا التصعيد البعض
يعتبروا بانه خطير جدا وتداعياته خطيره
جدا هل اوكرانيا مستعده
لحرب مفتوحه هل قادره ان تبقى صامده
والله نحن نحود الحرب الحرب الدفاعيه منذ
14 منذ سنه 2014
[موسيقى]
من زمان من زمان بس غايه الحرب كان غير
مولده وغير معروفه لكثير من يعني
[موسيقى]
بلدان والشعوب في العالم بس ابتداء منذ 24
فبراير هذه سنه
الناس عرفوا شو ماذا يجري هنا في اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا اكبر دوله مساحه في اوروبا على
فكره الان
18% من مساحه اوكرانيا مختله بالروس فهو
يقولون حتى اخذوا قوانين الجديده
وكاتبوا في الدستور
الروسي روسيا بان هذه المحافظات تابع
للروس عباده ونحن في قرن 21
اي معقول ام لا
المفاوضات والمسار السياسي برايكم غير
قابل للحديث عنه بهذه الاوقات
جيدا بان كل العرب حرب تنتهي بالسلام
بمفردات السلام ولكن ماذا بدنا نحن
يعني سلام عادل ونحن
نريد
سياده اراضينا
واستقلال اوكرانيا
واوكرانيا في حدود 91 طب ما هي حدود هذه
التنازلات سيد ماكتينكو للوصول الى سلام
يعني من المعروف عندما يكون هناك صراع
وحرب او عمليات عسكريه يجب على الطرفين ان
يقدم بعض التنازلات ما هو حدود هذا
التنازل من قبل اوكرانيا حتى حتى تنهى هذه
الحرب حتى تنتهي هذه الازمه
انا بقول لك صراحه انا يعني كنت اشاهد
كثير من الازمات
خصيصا في شرق الاوسط الازمه في لبنان
الازمه الحرب العراقيه ايرانيه والى اخره
الى اخره يعني محادثات السلام
تحتاج الى الهدوم
خلينا لا نستاجر وخلينا الناس المسؤولين
سوف يبدا محادثات محادثات بس على اسس
السليمه وعادله زي ما قالها
في محكمه هاي
فم
متطلباتنا عادله شكرا لك شكرا لك
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات